[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hello,
and welcome to
YouTube Develops Live.
My name is Jarek Wilkiewicz, and
as always, we have a very
exciting show for you today.
I am honored to introduce
my guest today, Max
Kanat-Alexander.
How are you doing, Max?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Great.
Thanks, Jarek.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And Max will
talk about code simplicity.
You might know that he's the
author of a book named aptly
"Code Simplicity," published
by O'Reilly.
When did the book come out?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER:
Last April.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK, great.
So if you haven't read the book,
today Max will give you
an overview of what
it is about.
And hopefully, you will be able
to learn more after this
talk, and reach out and get the
book to get the details.
So let's talk a little
bit about you, Max.
So can you tell me what
got you into software
in the first place?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER:
Yeah, sure.
I think that it started
when I was younger.
And I think like a lot of
programmers, probably when I
was in elementary school, they
sat me down in front of a
machine with Logo.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
I remember Logo.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yeah.
Most programmers that I talk
to, actually they started
either with Logo or with
HyperCard, because it was a
system that allowed you
to immediately see the
results of your work.
And I think, to this day, for
most programmers, the magic of
programming is asking the
computer to do something and
then seeing it actually
happen.
And I, to this day think,
that's actually a really
important experience for brand
new programmers to have.
If you load them down for their
very first experience
with a bunch of theory and
don't let them actually
accomplish something or give
them very complex tools to
start off with, then people
don't become as interested in
programming.
But when you give somebody that
little turtle and you
just be like, hey, here's some
commands you can use to move
the turtle around the screen
and it draws lines.
Then you're like, oh my
gosh, this is magical.
Then people suddenly
interested in being
programmers.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
So it looks like got into
software because of a turtle.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER:
Yeah, I think so.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So tell
me more about-- what
do you do at YouTube?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Sure.
So I am the technical lead for
developer productivity, which
means that I am in charge of the
tools that the developers
use internally.
I'm in charge of promoting best
practices throughout the
organization.
And basically, just
unblocking people.
In a technical sense, making
sure that everything is happy
and that code is simple and easy
to work with, and those
sorts of things.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
So in a nutshell, making sure
that YouTube will work as
advertised?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yes.
Or at least making sure that
YouTube will work as
advertised in the future.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
Yeah, I know this is a great
segue to your presentation,
because I know that you're
talking about the future value
of the software and the
maintenance and so forth.
So let's transition into the
more formal part of this
presentation today.
And I'll hand it over to you.
And tell us more about
code simplicity.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Sure.
Great.
So first, let me give a little
bit more overview of who I am
so everybody understands.
Like I said, I'm the technical
lead for development
productivity at YouTube.
I used to be the chief architect
of a particular
piece of open source software
called Bugzilla, which I spent
many years refactoring.
It used to have a very
bad code base.
And it was a code base, which
actually, everybody had to see
because everybody wants
to customize their
bug tracking system.
So it wasn't just the developers
who were being
affected by the bad code base,
but it was actually a lot of
our users because they actually
had to modify the
code, unlike many products.
And I wrote a book called "Code
Simplicity." I also have
a blog by the same name
at that domain name,
codesimplicity.com.
And I have a lot of
other things.
And there's a link to
my personal website
there on the slide.
And today, I'm going to be
talking about software.
And in particular, I'm going to
be talking about the laws
of software, and basically
fundamental principles that we
can use to make good decisions
about software.
So one of the problems that we
have today is that software
development is really complex.
When I talk to most programmers,
the systems that
they're doing with are
very complex systems.
And so many people feel like
that's just the way that life
is in the world of software
development
because it's so pervasive.
Well, it doesn't actually
have to be that way.
There are projects that aren't
complex, which sort of
disproves this theory that
that's just the way it is.
And I did a lot of research into
why this was happening
for people.
And what I discovered is that
the fundamental underlying
reasons have to do with
understanding.
Particularly, understanding how
to make decisions, what
principles to follow.
And the more junior an engineer
is, the harder it is
for them to know-- how do I know
that this decision is the
right decision?
And the reason that that's hard
is because in the field
of software engineering, most of
our most important lessons
are learned through
experience.
And that means that not
everybody has all the
experience.
And particularly, the newer
you are, the less
experience you have.
And since there's always new
people coming into the field,
there's always a lot of IT
people with not enough
experience to make decisions
who have to make decisions.
Because that's basically one of
your most important jobs as
a programmer, is to
make decisions.
And even if you're an
experienced programmer, you
might not have all of the
experience required to make
the right decisions for every
situation because your
experience might not have
covered that situation.
So you might still be
new in something.
And also, not everybody has
the same vocabulary.
If we want to talk about
these concepts, we
need words to share.
We need ideas that
we can agree on.
A couple years ago, the idea
of technical debt, for
example, became very popular
and widespread.
And before that, we didn't
have a word for that.
And when people didn't have a
word for that, it was much,
much harder for them
to talk about.
But now it's easy for everyone
And particularly, it's easy
for technical people to
communicate to nontechnical
managers about why they need
to do the work that they're
trying to do to
improve code quality.
And that's what I want to have
people be able to do is to be
able to talk about why they're
doing what they're doing in an
intelligent way.
Because once you can communicate
about it, you can
get team agreement on it,
and you can actually
make progress forward.
So my solution to this problem
was to come up with something
that I called the laws of
software design, which are
basically the most fundamental
or most
important facts about software.
And today, I'm just going to
give a real whirlwind tour.
Obviously, there's a whole book
on this subject, which is
my book, "Code Simplicity." And
I'm just going to touch on
it really lightly, and
the book goes into it
in much more detail.
So one of the things that people
tell me after I read
them some of these things
is they say,
well, that was obvious.
I already knew a lot
of those things.
Well, that might be true.
But what matters here is that
there's a sea of data in the
field of software engineering.
There's all kinds of opinions.
There's all kinds
of information.
And what matters is that we pick
out the most important
pieces and we recognize that
those are the pieces that we
use to judge our decisions
against.
Because otherwise there's lots
of conflicting data.
There's lots of different ways
we can make decisions.
We need to know what the most
important information is, so
that we can use those to judge
other information.
That's why you need a structure
of information, so
that you can use the senior
information to judge the more
junior information.
And when people tell me that
this is obvious-- so, just for
a second, like off the top of
your head, could you list the
five or six most important
facts about software
engineering?
Just think about that
for a second.
I'll give you a couple
seconds.
That's hard, right?
It's hard to just pick out--
like, oh my gosh, off the top
my head, what are the
five most important
things that I know?
And also, as I mentioned before,
we need to be able to
communicate these ideas
to other developers.
So even if we kind of inherently
or instinctively
knew some of these things, it's
very hard for a lot of us
to put them into words, and
thus explain them to more
junior developers or explain
them to our managers.
And if we can't do that, we
can't make progress forward
because software development in
the real world is mostly a
team activity.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So I have
a question about the
last point you made.
You're saying that we need to
be able to communicate the
ideas and communicate
about the idea.
So can you explain what
the difference is?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Sure.
There's not really a lot
of difference, but--
the ideas themselves
are the laws.
And then communicating about the
ideas would be like, well,
how are we going to use these
in our day-to-day work?
So we're going to dive
right into it.
And our first principle
is what I call
the purpose of software.
And this is not exactly a law.
The book talks about the
definition that I'm using for
these words, which is slightly
different than the traditional
definitions that people
have for these words.
Basically, I'm very much opposed
to inventing new
words, so I just tend to take
existing words and use them in
ways that are valid in English,
but which people are
not necessarily always
as familiar with.
But this is not a law.
This is sort of a guiding
principle.
When you have a science or a
way of looking at data, you
need a way to know that- you
need to know what you're
accomplishing.
You need to have a guideline by
which you can judge whether
or not your laws are
accomplishing what you're
trying to do.
You need a purpose.
You need to know where
you're going.
And then you can say, this
science or this study is valid
because it accomplishes
this purpose.
And that's more or less the only
way to validate many of
these things.
Particularly in something
that's almost a social
science, like software
engineering.
And I looked around for a very
long time for a phrase that I
thought would encompass the
purpose of all software.
And I found one that I have not
been able to disprove yet.
And that is that software
exists to help people.
Sometimes people come up to me
immediately after I say this
and they're like, well,
what about viruses?
Well, viruses do exist
to help people.
They just exist to help
different people than you'd
think, or help people
in different
ways than you'd think.
When you talked to
virus writers--
I remember reading an interview
with a virus writer
many years ago.
And he said, I'm trying
to help people realize
how stupid they are.
Or, how much more careful
they should
be with their computers.
Or sometimes, if they're virus
writers for a government or
for an intelligence
organization, then they're
helping that government
or they're helping the
intelligence organization.
And so there's definitely a
subjective aspect to this.
But what's most important here
is that software is not
written to help the computer.
Even if you're writing
libraries, you're writing
those libraries to help
other programmers,
not to help the computer.
Even network stack stuff
is there to help
somebody, some person.
It's not there to help
the computer.
And I mentioned there's a
subjective component to this,
but I would like to encourage
people to be more
objective about it.
To look at, how do you actually
help people on the
broad scale?
How do you help people
across the world?
How do you help people in your
organization or in other
organizations?
And then also, how do
you help yourself?
I mean, that is valid.
It might be a little less
important on the scale, but
it's still an important fact.
And part of the subjective
component is that the word
"help--" like, what
is helpful to
different people is different.
But the word has a dictionary
definition, and it means to
make it easier for a person to
do something, often to do part
of the work of a person.
That is, more or less, straight
out of the Webster's
Third New International
Dictionary.
And this is also useful because
you can state the
specific purpose for your
software by picking the group
of people you're
trying to help.
And then, what you're trying
to help them do.
So for example, if I write a
piece of accounting software
for accountants and it's
designed to help accountants
do taxes for others, then I can
just say the purpose of my
software is to help accountants
do taxes.
And one of the nice things about
this is it allows us to
very specifically state what
the focus of our system is.
And more focused systems
are usually
better for their users.
It also allows us to rank
features, so we can be like,
hey, this feature helps
accountants do taxes more than
other features.
It gives us a guideline against
which we can actually
use to make these judgments.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So the
manifestation of that would be
some sort of a human-centric
design?
And I think, to a certain
extent, use cases or
contextual design falls into
that category, where you
actually have somebody
in mind when you're
building it, right?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yeah.
I think it's important many
times to not have just one
person in mind, because you're
trying to help a
whole group of people.
And so I've occasionally seen
this model fall flat if people
try to do too much
categorization of their users.
But I think some categorization
of your users
is good, as long as you either
try to find a set of
categories that are broad
enough that they cover
everyone or you recognize that
you're not covering everyone
and that ultimately, the purpose
is to help the whole
group of people.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sure.
That's the purpose of
personas, right?
This is what people
use personas for?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER:
Yeah, exactly.
And I've seen people misuse
personas in these cases.
And so I always want to be
careful when people are using
personas that they're using them
intelligently, because
that's what makes
them valuable.
So now we get into our first
law, and this first law is
something that I call the
equation of software design.
And it basically states that the
desirability of any change
is directly proportional to the
value of the change, which
is how much it helps people, our
previous law, versus the
effort involved in making the
change, which is just the
total time that it takes to make
the change, including all
the work that you have
to do-- bug tracking,
everything like that.
And what we can use
this for is we can
use it to rank decisions.
In the field of software design,
there's no absolutely
right or absolutely
wrong decisions.
There's only decisions that are
better than other decisions.
And eventually, sometimes you
get to the point where there
are two or three decisions that
are all equally good.
But usually, then you're
in a good state.
As long as you've eliminated all
the bad decisions and you
have a bunch of different
decisions that are good that
you can pick between,
I'm happy for you
to have that problem.
Although, however, this is the
overly simplistic version of
the equation.
Because really, in reality,
desirability and software has
a time component to it.
We maintain systems over time.
So the full version of the
equation looks like this.
It says that the desirability
of any particular change is
proportional to the sum of the
value now plus the future
value and inversely proportional
to the effort of
implementation plus the
effort of maintenance.
Now, one thing that we can look
at here-- and what I mean
by value now is I mean the value
basically right when you
release it, or right when
it hits the user.
It depends, but you'll have a
sense for yourself of when the
now is versus when
the future is.
And the effort of implementation
is all the
effort that it took to get to
the value now, the immediate
value of the system.
And like I said, usually
that's when
it's released to users.
First is future--
and those are both constants.
So the value now and
the effort of
implementation are constants.
And the value in the future
is a function of time.
And the effort of maintenance
And software tends to have very
long time lines, which
means that, in general, we
tend to be looking at the
limit of this equation as time
goes on, or time approaches
infinity for those of us who did
calculus, which is a lot
of programmers.
And so what happens is the
equation actually reduces at
the limit to the desirability of
any particular change being
proportional to the future
value and inversely
proportional to its effort
of maintenance only.
That the constants drop away
as you go into the future.
And I think that this is
something that people often
forget when they're very caught
up in the effort of
implementation, because there's
a lot of effort in
implementation and the effort
of maintenance in the future
is not yet realized.
You don't see it yet.
But it's there and it's usually
much more important.
Particularly because when you
make changes to your system,
you're influencing the
maintenance of other parts of
your system.
So you're increasing the
maintenance of the overall
system and you're making
everything less desirable as
you add more and more
maintenance in the future.
So it's important for us to
think now about how we reduce
future maintenance.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: One question
about this equation.
So you were talking earlier
about technical debt.
So how does technical debt
picture into this?
Does it increase the em
right off the bat?
How does it work?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER:
That's pretty much
exactly what it does.
So a good guideline is that you
can accumulate technical
debt for about three weeks
without it affecting you.
And then, about three weeks into
it, the technical debt
that you incurred three weeks
ago will actually start
slowing you down so much that it
wasn't worth incurring the
technical debt.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Interesting.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yeah.
And that is what you're doing,
you're increasing the effort
of maintenance.
And our goal as software
designers, if we talk about
the field of software design
as a sort of a subset of
software engineering, is to
avoid situations where the
future value becomes outweighed
by the effort of
maintenance.
The idea is that the future
value of any change you make
increases and increases and
increases, and the effort of
maintenance decreases.
That's the ideal, but any
situation in which the future
value increases faster
than the effort--
they could both go up.
As long as the future value is
getting bigger and bigger and
bigger, you're fine.
But what this tells us most
importantly is that it's more
important to reduce the effort
of maintenance than it is to
reduce the effort of
implementation.
That if you have to do sort of
a balancing of work, you want
to do more work at
implementation time if that
means less work at
maintenance time.
However, there's definitely
some catches to that.
You don't want to add a lot of
complexity to the system in
order to sort of handle future
maintenance that you don't
know whether it's going to
be necessary or not.
And we're going to
get into that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: This is very
difficult to do, though.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yes.
This is very difficult to do.
Although, I have some guidelines
that I think--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: You're going
to show us how to do it?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yeah.
This is my goal.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Looking
forward to it.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yeah.
Now, one thing though, to know
about the future, is that it's
very hard to predict.
Like I said, software has
very long time lines.
Even things that you expect to
live for a very short period
of time are likely to live
for months or years.
And that the farther things
get into the future, the
harder and harder it
is to predict.
And as a result, any time that
you start predicting the
future, you have a chance
of being wrong.
Any time you start making a
decision now based on the
specifics of something you
think will happen in the
future, there's a reasonable
chance you'll be wrong.
Most people, they know
what they're
going to have for lunch.
And maybe they have some sense
of when they're going to be
leaving work.
But if you think about all the
times that you were wrong
about when you were going to
leave work, you can realize
that it doesn't have to be a
very long time horizon before
your predictions start
becoming relatively
inaccurate.
And since we're designing these
systems where our future
is really important, it's
important that we don't make
inaccurate statements
about the future.
One of the most disastrous
errors that programmers make
is making some statement about
the future when, in fact, you
can't know that.
When you act as though you can
know, when really you can't.
For example, people say,
we will never have
to reuse this code.
You don't know that.
You might be right, you
might be wrong.
People might say, well, we'll
never have to handle any other
input to this method than what
it's getting now, or input to
this class than what
it's getting now.
Well, you might be right,
you might be wrong.
And sometimes you do have
to make assumptions.
For example, with
internationalization, it can
be very hard to bolt
that on later.
But you have to be aware that
what you're doing is an
assumption.
And you have to make it in some
way that it doesn't block
you in for the future.
It doesn't cause your future
to become unchangeable or
inflexible because you
could be wrong.
You always have to sort
of hedge your bets.
For example, with
internationalization
frameworks, what I tell people
is you might start off only
need the thing in English.
So just try to use
internationalization framework
that adds very, very little
complexity to the system.
And we're going to get
into why that is a
little bit more later.
But that will basically make
sure that you're not going to
box yourself in.
What I recommend to developers
is that--
and this is going to sound a
little contradictory and I'm
going to get into this
resolution of the
contradiction, is that you
don't make specific
predictions about the future.
Instead, what you should do is
you should understand the
principles of software design
and use those principles and
the rules and best practices to
understand how you can make
decisions now that will lead
to a good future no matter
what happens.
I told you at the beginning for
the equation of software
design, I said the most
important thing is the effort
of maintenance and the future
value, which is
all about the future.
And then I told you, but really,
don't make decisions
about the future.
So this sounds like
a contradiction,
but really it's not.
There's a difference between
designing right now in a way
that is guaranteed to reduce
future maintenance, which is
what I want you to do, versus
attempting to predict
something specific about the
future, like this platform
will always be maintained.
Or, there's going to
be x number of
developers using our framework.
Or, nobody will ever
need another
part of this API response.
Those are decisions, specific
things about the future that
you're predicting that
you can't know.
Whereas, if you say, OK, right
now, we know that the purpose
of software is to help people.
The purpose of software is going
to always be to help
people, and so that can guide
our future decisions.
That's a good way of making a
decision about the future, is
things that you know will always
be true and will always
help things be better, rather
than very specific things that
you might be wrong about.
So one of the things that we
can know about the future,
with fair certainty--
with actually, total
certainty--
is that the longer your program
exists, the more
probable it is that any piece
of it will have to change.
Basically you can think
of this as a
reflection of entropy.
That the universe is going to
change around you, and that as
long as you want your system
to continue to help people,
you're going to have
to change it.
Because you're going to have
to adapt it to the changing
needs of the universe.
Or, maybe it doesn't even fully
fulfill its users needs
yet, which is most pieces
of software.
You're still adding features
to fully fulfill, even the
presently known needs.
It's impossible to make a system
that doesn't change but
continues to help people just
as well as it does now.
The helpfulness of a piece
of software decays
if it is not changed.
Many people believe that it is
possible to do this and they
make bad decisions based
on this belief.
Now, when people get into trying
to change pieces of
software, there's three
major classes of
mistakes that they make.
And I give a whole presentation
on these three
major classes and there's a
whole section in the book
about them, but here I'm
just going to go
over them really briefly.
The first is that they write
code that isn't needed.
They think, I'm going to need
this code in the future, and
so they write it now.
And there's this philosophy in
extreme programming called you
ain't going to need it, which
sort of forbids doing this.
But I think that that phrasing
is wrong, because--
and it's hard to convince
people that way.
Because sometimes
you do need it.
Sometimes you were right
and you did need
this piece of software.
But what you don't know is you
don't know what the real
requirements of the future are
until you reach the future.
So you don't know exactly how
the software should be written
or what's the most ideal
way to write it
until the future comes.
So what usually ends up
happening is you write it now,
and then you don't
need it now.
And then you end up rewriting it
in the future when the real
future comes, or you don't
rewrite it and then you have
to hack around it because it's
not what you really need.
So you're basically wasting
effort right now by writing
software that you're going
to need in the future.
The second is not making the
code easy to change.
And usually, this is just
lack of design.
Like the simplest way to do
this is just to not think
about the design, not understand
best practices.
If you're working in an
object-oriented language,
don't write object-oriented
code.
If you're working in a
functional language, don't
write sensible functional
patterns.
Don't think about the design
of your functions.
And you're going to get into a
system that just is enormously
difficult to change.
And the change is the one
constant that we have that
we're sure about.
So that's the thing that
you really do need to
design for, is change.
And so there's two.
I probably should have written
them on the slide--
rigid design and--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So the third
one you have listed here is
being too generic.
And frankly, this is one of the
traps that I find myself
falling into all the time.
And it's related to the first
one, because I'm trying to
anticipate the need, so I
want to make it generic.
But then it's really
complicated design.
So how do you find the balance
between allowing for future
change, like you said in the
previous slide, because change
is going to come.
This is inevitable.
But then, at the same time, not
being too generic so the
code is easy to read and so
forth, like this is something
that I personally
struggled with.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER:
Yeah, that's a
really great question.
And it was something that I
struggled with too for a while
in my career.
And I found a principle that
basically resolves it.
And so yeah, so being too
generic is a problem.
And it's a very serious
problem.
So what I see is that junior
engineers tend to have the
under-designing problem and
senior engineers tend to have
this over-engineering problem,
being too generic.
Because they've experienced the
pain of inflexible systems
and now they want to
handle the problem.
But then, they design a system
that is generic in ways that
they don't know if it
needs to be generic
or not for the future.
And my principle is that
you can handle this
problem if you just--
very similar to a lot of the
other solutions here is, if
you focus on being only as
generic as you need to be
right now and you get really
accustomed to refactoring.
So it is important to be as
generic as the system
presently needs it to be.
But whenever you're making
predictions about future
genericness, you could be
wrong and you could be
wasting your time.
And in fact, it's likely that
you're wasting your time
because you could just wait for
the future to arrive and
then re-design the system
appropriately then.
So what I encourage people to
do is be as generic as you
need to be so that you never
duplicate code and that your
system always remains
simple enough.
And particularly, that
it remains stable.
So sometimes you need a level
of genericness to, for
example, handle multi-threading
appropriately,
even though there's only
one part of your system
that's using it.
But more often, what you'll find
is you suddenly have two
things that look similar.
And at that very instant,
that's when you need the
generic functionality.
But you need it to be only as
generic as it needs to be to
handle those two
specific cases.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Got it.
Cool.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Cool.
And that actually, pretty much
wraps up that slide for us.
So that brings us onto our next
law, which is the law of
defect probability.
And this is a fairly well-known
fact, but I think
it's useful to categorize it up
here as something that we
can use to make decisions
about it on
a very senior level.
And it says, "the chance of
introducing a defect into your
program is proportional to the
size of changes you make to
it."
I mean, this is obvious, but
it's useful for the framework
purposes to point out that
defects are basically things
that don't help people.
I mean, that's not the exact
definition of a bug, but it's
a good way to look at it.
There are no perfect
programmers.
Studies tend to show that very
good programmers, the best
programmers will introduce 1
bug per about 100 lines of
codes that they're writing.
And that under the very best
possible circumstances,
meaning the strictest
guidelines, meaning you're
moving very slowly and you're
doing a lot of testing and
it's just an onerous burden,
programmers will introduce
about one bug for every thousand
lines of code that
they write.
But that is extreme
circumstances.
So you're going to add
bugs, basically.
And you're going to add them
mostly in proportion to the
size of the changes that you're
making to the system.
And if we combine all three of
our laws, so our equation of
software design and the law of
change and the law of defect
probability, we start to
develop a philosophy.
And this is a philosophy that
many people know, but this
helps justify why we should
be doing this.
The best design is the one
that allows for the most
change outside of us in the
environment, because that's
what we're dealing with,
with the least
change in the software.
Or, at least, with small changes
or reasonably sized
changes in the software.
But it's important, like I said,
not to fall into the
trap of being too generic
to accomplish this.
It's not like, oh, we're going
to make everything into a
configuration file because
that allows us to
not change the code.
But the problem is that you're
adding complexity presently.
And we're going to get
into why that's bad.
And so I find that really
strictly designing for the
present and for your present
requirements and for things
that you know certainly
without excluding the
possibility of future
requirements is the best way
to accomplish this.
Just basically to keep in mind
that there's going to be
future requirements, and that
you want to keep your system
easy to refactor.
Not necessarily tiny numbers of
lines of code change, but
small logical changes
or simple to make
those logical changes.
Easy to make those
logical changes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Though,
refactoring likely increase
the number of lines of code that
need to change, right?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yes.
So there is that trade-off.
But what happens is, if you
design this way, you need to
refactor less and less and
less as time goes on.
And this is great because the
safest time to have defects in
your system is when you're
very early in
the development cycle.
So the fact that there's more
refactoring at the beginning
of the development cycle than
there is at the end is
actually ideal.
Now finally, well, this is
actually our final law, but we
have finally gotten to
the keystone law.
And this is the most important
part of the book.
And this is the part that I
spend the longest time on,
even though here we're
going to spend very
little time on it.
And that is the law
of simplicity.
And it tells us how to reduce
the future effort of
maintenance without
having to predict
anything about the future.
And it says the ease of
maintenance of any piece of
software is proportional to
the simplicity of its
individual pieces.
And what do I mean
by simplicity?
Well, the easiest way to think
about simplicity is, how easy
can each piece of this system
be understood and correctly
used by others?
How fast is it for me to--
I look at this piece of code.
I understand exactly what its
purpose is, and I know
instantly the right way to use
it so it's impossible for me
to mess it up or make bugs with
it or introduce problems
into the system.
Now, you'll notice that I didn't
say the simplicity of
the complexity of the whole
system, I said only its
individual pieces.
And the reason is that any
piece of software of
reasonable size or even of
average size, is so complex
that no human being can hold it
in their mind all at once.
If you think of even pieces of
software with very simple
feature sets.
For example, Twitter.
It does like fundamentally
three or four things when
you're looking at it
from the outside.
It's just a list of 140
characters things.
You can follow people.
They can follow you.
You can search.
You can make lists.
And people have profiles.
And that's really the major
functionality of the system.
And talking to you about
it here, it's very
easy to talk about.
But I can promise you that
the code base of
Twitter is so complex--
I haven't seen it, but I'm sure
that no human being could
hold it in their mind
all at once.
So you always have a
very complex system
for your entire system.
And your only hope is to the
parts that people need--
but the thing is, nobody needs
to understand the entire
system all at once in
order to modify it.
If they do, your system is
hopelessly complex and
impossible to modify.
That is a system where you
have not enough design.
This sort of ties back into
our earlier system.
And what you're trying to do is
you're trying to make the
parts that people need to modify
or the parts people
need to understand, simple
enough that they can
understand and modify them.
And this also gives you
guidelines for sort of how you
would componentize
your system.
You would componentize it in a
way that people can understand
the parts that they
need to change.
It's also important because
complexity is compounding.
So when you have one piece of
your system and it adds
complexity, and then you have
another piece of your system,
you add another change and
it adds complexity.
And then you add another change
and it adds complexity
to the whole system, you're
increasing the complexity of
each previous piece every time
you add a new piece.
And so you need to be sure that
you're focusing on the
simplicity of the individual
pieces, so that they're adding
as little complexity as possible
to the rest of the
system, or so that they're not
compounding the complexity of
the entire system.
And as far as how you accomplish
this and where this
complexity comes from, that's
a whole chapter of the book,
which is actually, many
sub-chapters.
It's the largest part
of the book.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And in your
experience, how do you measure
simplicity or complexity?
I know in the past people have
used, like cyclomatic
complexity to try to use tools
and things like that.
How do you actually do that?
Is it something that we just
know or something more formal?
Or do you get into that in-depth
in the book and we
should just refer our live
viewers today to the book?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: No,
actually, it's a good question.
So I think that in
the industry--
and there has been a lot of
opposition to metrics, because
they've been misused to judge
developers, to judge
individual developers.
I think metrics are valuable.
And they can give you hints
of where you should
look at your code.
Things like cyclomatic
complexity can be useful for
understanding the complexity--
finding your most complex
functions.
Cyclomatic complexity is not
necessarily good for finding,
say, the complexity of your
entire system, or even of a
whole class.
But it's good for finding
some bad candidates.
If your code base is
particularly problematic, then
it's going to find those most
problematic functions.
But it's not the most reliable
indicator of complexity of the
whole system.
In my experience, the most
reliable indicator of
complexity of the system is
asking the developers what
they think.
Because most developers in most
systems have a sense of--
even if they don't have a sense
of this is complex, they
have a sense of this is
frustrating or I can't move as
quickly as I need to.
Or it's hard to make changes
to this part of the system.
They have a sense of fragility,
which indicates
complexity.
And they have a sense of
velocity, which indicates
complexity.
And the nice thing about that
is it's a relatively
independent metric.
You don't need some other metric
to measure it against.
And like I said, there is a
social science aspect to
software engineering.
And so I'm more likely
to go and--
and there's also, of course,
quote unquote, "expert
judgement." Expert judgment
is also a reasonable
way of doing this.
If you have somebody who is an
expert and they look at the
system and they say, well,
this is pretty complex.
And then you can validate that
with all the other developers
saying, oh, yeah, we agree that
there's a problem here.
Maybe they don't see that the
problem is complexity, but
they see there's
a problem here.
That's much more what
I tend to go on.
When I come into a project and
I want to find out what the
complexity is like, I go around
and I talk to the
individual developers.
I say, what's blocking you?
What are the problems
that you have?
What's frustrating?
Are there other teams?
Are there other parts of the
system that you find
hard to work with?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I guess it's
no secret that Google does a
lot of code reviews.
So I think for developers who
are watching us right now,
they could also use the code
review process as a great
indication of simplicity or
complexity of their modules
based on the feedback
they're getting?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER:
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, particularly if you
have good code reviewers.
One of the things I'd love to
do some day is write a book
about good code review because
I actually have a lot to say
about it and I've never really
gotten to write it up.
But there's a lot of good
things to know there.
Actually, just since you asked,
I'm going to talk about
a couple of them.
One of them is you want to make
sure that you understand
every line of code.
And you never want to assume
that you don't understand it
just because you're stupid.
Because software is a
knowledge system.
This is actually the philosophy
that underlies code
simplicity on all
these things.
There's this sort of philosophy
of knowledge that
underlies it.
And it's that software is
a system of knowledge.
That's basically what
it is, right?
That's what code is,
is it's just the
representation of ideas.
Since they're ideas, what's most
important about that is
that they can be understood
or seen.
And if you're being communicated
an idea that you
can't understand, then you
shouldn't assume that it's
because you're stupid.
You should assume that it's
because the idea is too hard
to understand.
You are also a programmer,
right?
If I had to pick just one thing
to talk to people about
code review, I'd be like, just
keep asking people, could you
clarify this?
Could you clarify this?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Very helpful.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yeah.
Great.
And that brings us to
our last law, which
is the law of testing.
There's this famous quote from
Knuth, which is "Beware of
bugs in the above code, I have
only proved it correct.
I have not actually
tried to run it."
And basically, what this tells
us is that to a large degree,
what we know about code we know
empirically, which means
by observation, by test
or experiment.
The system is so complex that
it's hard to make judgements
about it or statements about
in the abstract.
Also, software runs on real
machines and you can't always
predict the behavior of the real
world in response to your
software without actually
running the real world against
your software.
And our law here is that the
degree to which you know how
your software behaves is
the degree to which
you've tested it.
And another way to say this
would be unless you tested it,
you don't know if it works.
But what does works mean?
People don't tell you.
Like, I hear a lot of people,
particularly in the field of
testing say, oh, we want to be
sure that the software works.
But what does works mean?
Works means it behaves as
you intended it to.
And that's what your tests
are really telling you.
They're not really telling you
works or doesn't work.
They're telling you about the
behavior of your system.
And the nice thing about this
law is it helps us have an
idea of what we should test
and how we should test it,
which I think can be very
contentious facts in a team
when you don't have
some guideline.
Otherwise, people just start
looking at code coverage.
They say, oh, well, our goal is
to have 100% code coverage.
But you might have tests which
run the code but aren't
actually testing the behavior or
telling you anything about
the behavior of it.
And thus, aren't valid test,
even though your coverage
number is very high.
So people often ask me, well,
so we've got these laws.
How do I actually use them?
Well, like I said, you
use them to make
decisions about software.
And so I'm going to go over a
couple of situations that
people commonly come across and
say how we can apply the
laws to make sensible and good
decisions in those areas.
So first, let's try answering
a question.
A common question is,
I've got a test.
Should I have a mock
in this test?
Should I mock out some
part of this test?
And for anybody who's watching
who doesn't know, a mock is
basically a piece-- a fake part
of the system that you
use to ensure reliability
or speed.
There's just some part of your
system that you don't want to
have there in your test, you
don't want to have the real
one, so you want to
use a fake piece.
So we basically have three
principles we can use to
evaluate the decision of
when to use a mock.
And the first is that--
our law of testing, which we
just went over, the degree to
which you know how your software
behaves is the degree
to which you've tested it.
When you have a mock
in your test, you
are testing the mock.
You are not testing
the system.
And you have to realize that
you might be overlooking an
interaction between your
component and the other
component that is not
being tested because
you're testing the mock.
And testing the mock is
inherently useless.
You care how your software
behaves, you don't care how
your mock behaves.
That's not what you're
trying to figure out.
Secondly, is that the longer
your program exists, the more
probable it is that any piece
of it will have to change.
And tests are also part
of your system.
They're also code
in the system.
And you're going to have to
maintain the test just like
you're going to have to maintain
the software itself.
And when you add mocks, you're
adding more code.
You're adding more code
both to the mocks.
And frequently, you're also
adding more code to the tests
themselves.
And this is adding to your
effort of maintenance.
However, the purpose of software
is to help people.
And even tests have
this purpose.
Who are tests helping?
Tests are helping a fair bit,
a fair number of people.
But mostly, most importantly,
tests are helping the
developers.
Really, this is senior
to all other things.
The purpose of software to help
people is senior to all
other things.
You can disregard all things if
you believe that you have
an argument which means this
will help people more.
And since tests are helping
programmers, there's a couple
of things that don't
help programmers.
And those are slow tests
and flaky tests.
And by flaky tests, for anybody
who doesn't know, I
mean tests that--
they fail when there's nothing
wrong with your software.
And they fail randomly and
they aren't predictive.
So if a mock makes
your test faster,
then that helps people.
And that is a really good
use of the mock.
If it turns a test that is
unreliable into a test that is
reliable, then that's also
a very good mock.
There might be some
non-deterministic behavior and
you need to make that behavior
deterministic for your test.
And that's a very good
case to use a mock.
But we should take it into
consideration the previous two
things, so the law of testing,
which tells us that when we
fake things, we probably want
to fake as little of them as
possible as we need to make
things fast or deterministic
or helpful to the people who are
running the tests in some
way or another, helpful to the
developer of the tests or
helpful to the other
developers who
are running the test.
By the way, I want to point
that out, that it's not
necessarily the developer who's
writing the test who is
being helped by the test, it
is the other developers who
are using the system and who
want to know that their
changes didn't break you.
They're some of the
most important
people to care about.
People who can have certainty
that they don't need to
manually test every part of your
system just because they
change something about
their system.
But we want to be sure that
we're mocking out as little as
we need in order for
them to be helpful.
And that also helps keep our
mocks small in general, so
that they don't need
to be maintained.
Or you want to have one
centralized mock, so that it's
easier to maintain just that
one mock and you're not
inventing a bunch of
mocks all the time.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: One comment
I have about this is, in my
experience, using mocks in my
unit tests was very beneficial
to the speed and reliability.
But I found that most of my bugs
were actually found in
integration tests, which
use the real system.
But then those where typically
unreliable
and slow and so forth.
So it's always difficult
to reconcile these two
conflicting goals.
So how do you do that
in your experience?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: So there's
a couple of ways to
accomplish it.
Obviously, the ideal way to
accomplish it is to design
your system in such a way that
you don't need to mock out
very much in order for the
system to be fast or
deterministic.
All you need to do is mock out
the network, like the I/O
calls for example, and then
everything else is fast enough
for the tests to run.
And your goal should be that the
tests run in a couple of
seconds, ideally.
Because what you want is you
want a test suite that
developers can run over and over
and over while they're
doing development.
Like when you save a file, it'd
be great if the test just
ran instantly so you knew,
oh, look, I've got a bug.
Nobody will even see
it in production.
Sometimes people will say, oh,
my tests aren't useful because
they never fail on the
continuous integration build,
on the continuous build.
But that's not where tests
are most useful.
Tests are most useful for the
developer who's actually
making the changes right now and
letting them know that as
they go, oh, look, I've
made a mistake.
I can immediately fix
that mistake.
The CI system, the Continuous
Integration system, that's
useful for the release
engineers, so that they know
that things aren't broken.
And it's useful for the
architects of the system so
that they can see, oh, things
are going wrong.
So another way to deal with
this is just to have split
test suites, is to have the fast
tests that run while the
developers are working, and
then the integration tests
only run in continuous
integration.
it's a less ideal situation
because it means, like you
said, that you won't
catch as many bugs.
It really depends
on the project.
With a smaller number of
developers, I err on the side
of just making everything
an integration test.
And with a larger number of
developers, I err on the side
of faster tests.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
I think that's a
good heuristic.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thanks.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER:
So next, let's
look at a design question.
One question that comes up is,
should I design this piece of
code defensively?
That is, should I make sure
that it doesn't crash no
matter what happens
possibly, right?
Like it handles all possible
inputs, and it clones all the
objects that you pass it so
that it doesn't modify
anything outside of it.
And it does a bunch of things to
make sure that nothing bad
ever happens.
So the first question, the first
principle we can use
here, is that the ease of
maintenance of any piece of
software is proportional to
the simplicity of its
individual pieces.
And there's also the equation
of software design that I've
got there, where we care about
the effort of future
maintenance.
So that's really what
we care about.
And when we are adding code to
the system, we are usually
making it more complex.
That's not always true.
But if you're adding code that
adds logical components, like
actual new logic to the system,
then you are adding
complexity.
Sometimes more code is simpler,
like longer names are
sometimes a little bit better
than shorter name.
It depends on the circumstance,
and I talk about
that in the book, too.
Including a guideline about
how to name things, which
people have found
fairly helpful.
But in this case, when we're
adding defensiveness, we are
definitely adding complexity.
When we're handling all kinds
of different inputs, we're
adding complexity.
Also, as I mentioned
before, software
is a system of knowledge.
And if you hide errors, you
are making it hard to know
things about the system, which
is the most important thing
that you want to be able to do,
is you want to be able to
reason about or make
statements about
your software systems.
And when you hide errors, it
becomes very difficult to
reason about the behavior
of the system.
Particularly for
the developers.
However, as I mentioned before,
the future is full of
unforeseeable consequences.
And some functions, or some
classes, or some scripts, or
some binaries, are in situations
where they can't
predict the input that
they're going to get.
So there's really a divide.
There's internal code, which
can predict and make a
contract with the rest of the
system about what input it
accepts, and then there's
external externally-facing
code, which cannot predict the
input it's going to get.
And in this case, you have to
be defensive because of the
unforeseeable consequences
of the future.
And sometimes also, like at a
very high level of the system,
you want to have an exception
handler that's like, we don't
want to crash the system.
Obviously, if the YouTube API
crashed every time that it got
unexpected input, we wouldn't
have a YouTube API.
It just wouldn't
be functioning.
It gets unexpected input
continuously.
So in this case, that
defensiveness is critical.
But when you look at structuring
your code for
this, you still want to
consider the ease of
maintenance and simplicity.
So what you want to probably
do is, if you know that
there's a whole section or part
of the system that you're
going to want to have be
defensive, you want to try to
come up with a framework that
actually makes it as easy to
maintain this defensiveness
as possible.
And it's not just a bunch
of custom code in
every single function.
People have validation
frameworks and you want to try
to evaluate--
find a good validation
framework.
And I talk in the book about how
to evaluate technologies
and you can use some of
those principles.
And so that gives us
a pretty good way
of making this decision.
And I think one of the things
that I've tried to show in
this talk is that these are
not dogmatic principles.
I'm not telling you
what to do.
Instead, I'm telling you how
to make judgments in the
situation that you're in.
Because honestly, every
development
situation is different.
Every development situation
is custom.
And only the people on the
ground and who are looking at
that system right there can
make accurate judgments.
There's no dogmatic
system that works
in 100% of the time.
The only reliable system
is developer judgment.
And that brings us, if my slide
will advance, to the end
of the talk.
As I said, I have a blog.
I'm also available for
speaking stuff.
I'm happy to come to companies
and talk to people.
This is really my
mission in life.
As far as money, I
work at Google.
I get paid fine.
I have no problem with that.
And so I'm not here just
to make money.
I'm here really to help people
out and that's one of the
reasons I like to go
around and talk.
And there's also a book that I
wrote, which you can get to
from the link.
And it has lots of other
things, like where does
complexity come from?
It has a checklist that tells
you when you should rewrite
your system.
It has a checklist that tells
you when you should choose to
reinvent the wheel, so reinvent
an existing system.
And it has a ton of real-world
examples for
all of these things.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: This is a
great segue to a couple of the
questions that we have
in our moderator.
I was just looking and let's go
through this pretty quickly.
These are from Tim Wintle, who
is our Google Developer Expert
based out in UK.
Hello, Tim.
So first question, "In the
equation of software design,
how would you value
a blocking change?
For example, an underlying
infrastructure change which
doesn't reduce maintenance or
add value immediately, but
opens up a whole range
of possible
features, potential value?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: That's
a great question.
So I would look at that as
future value, which is
actually really great.
And it's important that it be
based on something that you
know is needed now.
You can look at the present
situation and you can be like,
we know that this scaling
situation is needed, or we
know that this piece of
infrastructure needs to be
used by the developers
in a particular way.
We've gone to the developers and
we've actually asked them,
what specifically do you need?
And then, we implemented
that specific thing.
Or we used our judgment to
fulfill their needs.
Obviously, you don't
want to just do
whatever your users say.
It's always the developers.
I have a blog post that I wrote,
which I think might be
my most recent blog post called
"Users Have Problems,
Developers Have Solutions." If
you're writing infrastructure,
then your users are
other programmers.
So you want to find out what
their problems are, but you
don't want to let them dictate
your solutions.
And you want to come up with
the solutions, but you want
those solutions to be based
on real-world problems.
And so that way, you are making
a better future based
on present time information.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So you have
to be pragmatic about it.
Don't fall for the latest shiny
thing because it may
actually bite you
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER:
Yeah, exactly.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So the second question is, "The
law of simplicity seems
to justify SOAs.
But at some point, dependency
management becomes complex
between intercorrecting
services.
How do you avoid passing the
overall systems complexity up
to operations?
For example, SREs at Google."
And for those of you that are
not familiar with the concept,
Google has a specific set of
engineers that are focused on
these types of deployment
issues.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yeah.
So that's an interesting
question.
And as far as Service-Oriented
Architectures, which is what
SOA stands for if anybody
doesn't know that, I think
that that varies.
I do encourage it for larger
teams in particular, because
it enforces API boundaries.
And that is often one of the
best ways to lead to broad
scale system simplicity is
enforcement of API boundaries.
What I would say is that if
you're going to write a
service-oriented architecture
and you're going to have the
operations people or SREs like
we have at Google, you need to
make sure that your tooling
is up to speed.
That you have a system that
allows operations to manage
the complexity here in
some simple way.
That there is some consistency
between how your services
behave, how they're brought up,
how they're brought down,
how they report information
about themselves, how you get
data about their current
performance, their current
memory usage, and things
like that.
And don't skimp out
on the tooling.
Don't think, oh, well, we've
made our side of the bargain.
On the software engineer
side, we've made
everything so simple.
And then just decide, oh, we're
going to dump all the
complexity on the SREs, which
I've definitely seen happen at
various places.
People will go, oh.
They don't think about the fact
that this system is going
to have to run in production.
And people are going to need to
understand things about it
not just at development time,
but also at production time.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I think from
my experience, building that
into the system, such as
reporting all these system
health metrics, really nicely
avoids the problem of getting
the 3:00 AM phone call.
Because chances are there's
someone who is actually
on-call and they'll take care
of it for you as long as you
have actually thought about
exposing that in your software
in the first place.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yeah.
So there's also a personal
motivation there, which is
that you don't want to
be called at 3:00 AM.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Absolutely.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yeah, I
don't want to be called at
3:00 AM, ever.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: We have
one more question.
And this is a question from
Jeremy Walker, my colleague.
And the question is, "Is Google
Developers relations
hiring?"
I'll take that.
Yes, we are hiring.
In order to learn more, go to
developers.google.com/jobs and
you'll see all the positions
that we have open, and you can
apply there.
Well, I think we ran
out of time.
Thank you very much,
Max, for coming.
I think this was a very
interesting and very
enlightening talk.
I think I'm definitely going to
buy the book after this and
read up more about it.
Thank you.
And then for those of you
watching, thank you very much
for your time.
And we'll see you again live
on YouTube at Wednesday at
10:00 AM Pacific,
like every week.
Bye.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]